موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم اقتحمت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باحات المسجد الاقصى
للمره الثانيه خلال 24 ساعه واعتدت على
المصلين خلال صلاه التراويح وافاد مراسل
الجزيره بانسحاب قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الى باب الاقصى واثارت اقتحامات قوات
الاحتلال المسجد الاقصى واعتداءاتها على
المصلين المعتكفين بداخله موجه اداناته من
دول عربيه واجنبيه
يعقد مجلس الامن الدولي اليوم الخميس جلسه
مشاورات مغلقه بشان تطورات في المسجد
الاقصى بناء على طلب فلسطينيين اردني
وعشيه الجلسه قال المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده سيفان دوجاريس يشعر
بالصدمه والفزع من صور العنف التي مارستها
القوات الاسرائيليه على المصلين في المسجد
القبلي بالمسجد الاقصى
حذر وزراء خارجيه الدول الاعضاء في حلف
شمال الاطلسي الصين من عواقب تقديم
مساعدات عسكريه لروسيا في حربها على
اوكرانيا وقال الامين العام لحلف شمال
الاطلسي يانس ان اي مساعده صينيه لروسيا
بالاسلحه الفتاكه ستكون خطا كبيرا وستنجم
عنها عواقب وخيمه
قال السفير الصيني لدى الاتحاد الاوروبي
ان بلاده لم تكن الى جانب روسيا في الحرب
على اوكرانيا وان بيجين لم تقدم مساعده
عسكريه لموسكو ولم تعترف بضم الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لروسيا بما في ذلك شبه جزيره
القرم ودومباس
اكد الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون ان
الحوار مع الصين
بامكانها ان تلعب دورا كبيرا لايجاد طريق
لتحقيق السلام في اوكرانيا وفي كلمتها
امام الجاليه الفرنسيه في بيجيم الاتحاد
الاوروبي لا يمكن ان يترك الحوار محصورا
فقط بين الصين وروسيا
قالت القوات الاوكرانيه انها وسعت نطاق
استخدام الطائرات المسيره لكشف مواقع
تمركز القوات الروسيه وقصفها في مدينه
اوكرانيا في الاثناء تعهدت واشنطن بمواصله
تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا بعد محادثات بين
قائدي الجيشين الامريكي والاوكراني سياسيا
وقع الرئيس الاوكراني
ورئيس الوزراء البولندي ماتيوسكي اتفاقيه
لتعزيز امداد اوكرانيا بالمعدات العسكريه
وتسلم مزيد من الدبابات شدد في خطاب وجهه
للاوكرانيين والبولنديين على ضروره ان
يكون هناك تحالف طيران لصالح اوكرانيا على
غرار تحالف الدبابات
اتهم الرئيس الروسي فلادمير بوتين
استخبارات غربيه بالوقوف وراء هجمات
اوكرانيه
وقال بوتين ان دعم الولايات المتحده لما
وصفه بالانقلاب في كييف عام 2014 اسفر عن
وقوع الازمه الاوكرانيه الراهنه
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]